et moi j'ai été choquée c'est pour ça
que je vous ai écrit d'ailleurs j'ai pas
fait de tweets mais vous savez on peut
s'écrire aussi on n'est pas tous obligé
de faire des trucs j'ai été choqué parce
que j'ai vu déjà le piège j'ai un peu de
métier donc j'ai vu la séquence où
effectivement à plusieurs reprises vous
essayez de faire retomber la pression et
lui il remet une pièce dans la machine
vous le décrypterez mais en tout cas
notamment quand vous vous retournez et
vous dites bon on va voir ce que pense
c'était les spectateurs on voit qu'il
repousse le sujet donc là j'ai trouvé
déjà c'était un traquenard pour vous et
en plus Louis Boyard pour moi c'est
vraiment le symbole de l'impolitesse
c'est vraiment quelqu'un qui se comporte
très mal à l'Assemblée nationale dans
les émissions avec lesquelles j'ai pu ce
que j'ai pu débattre avec lui enfin
débattre comme il n'a pas de conviction
c'est plus difficile mais si vous voulez
et c'était quand même stupéfaite parce
qu'il se permet de parler de politesse
alors qu'il met la honte à tous les
Français lui-même à l'Assemblée
nationale parce qu'il est vulgaire il
est mal habillé il ne respectent rien ni
personne ni les institutions ni les
forces de l'ordre
parce qu'en fait il dit que il fait il
met un point d'honneur à venir mal
habillé à l'Assemblée nationale il dit
je veux dire en basket écoutez moi ça me
dérange parce que je trouve que c'est
une image non mais je trouve qu'il faut
respecter l'institution et c'est
quelqu'un qui est d'une extrême
vulgarité et d'une extrême violence
parce que en fait c'est quelqu'un qui
est qui me remet en cause régulièrement
les skis enfin les choses qui
constituent même la République voilà je
sais que ça va vous énerver parce que je
fais un peu de politique mais l'histoire
est politique et se permettre comme ça
si vous voulez de parler d'un politesse
j'ai trouvé ça complètement dingue et
ensuite j'ai écouté aujourd'hui la
séquence à l'Assemblée nationale et là
où on voit la supercherie c'est qu'ils
vous redemande un débat c'est à dire
qu'il vous redemande un débat donc il y
a un moment la question que je me pose
je veux bien que tout le monde ne soit
pas habitué à l'émission mais on sait
très bien que l'émission ben on se fait
bousculer moi j'ai fait TPMP j'ai fait
BTP BTP c'est très difficile vous enfin
c'est vraiment une émission on sait
qu'il y a de la confrontation vous avez
pas été toujours été d'ailleurs quand
j'ai débattu avec lui pardon souvent
vous avez pris ça des fois vous en
remercie une
erreur de jugement à l'époque je pense
souvent on l'a regardé on l'a on l'a on
a un autre on a un autre extrait sur
TPMP ou je prends ça défense aussi parce
que vous lui avez accusé de faire monter
l'extrême droite à Louis Boyard regarde
on parle beaucoup du voile en Allemagne
ils en parlent en Angleterre
vous verrez elle a des petits sursauts
comme ça
c'est rien de grave voilà c'est comme ça
c'est comme ça et puis des fois
en disant ça lui Boyard lui fait monter
Zemmour ça c'est sûr
voilà donc c'est vrai que voilà c'était
bon
il est très content de prendre sa pige
et tout à l'heure on sort depuis tout à
l'heure on essaie de chercher du fond
dans ce que dit louer pardon mais il y a
aucun fond en fait on voit bien que
c'est juste un gratteur de buzz
quelqu'un qui vient sur les émissions de
télé dans un seul but c'est faire sa
promotion personnelle il suffit de voir
la manière dont il se met en scène sans
cesse et voilà en fait il n'y a aucun
fond dans ce qu'il dit tout ce qu'il
veut c'est faire du buzz et faire parler
de lui et c'est tout dangereux c'est
pour ça que je suis là aussi ce soir
mais vraiment parce que je suis très en
colère il est dangereux parce que il
amène une partie d'opinion avec lui
c'est ça et ça c'est une réalité j'ai
observé tout le weekend comme bon la
manière dont se sont passés les choses
si si c'est toujours mignon qui le
suivent mais mine de rien c'est un
problème parce que si vous voulez en
fait c'est un usurpateur c'est un
arnaqueur il n'a aucune conviction je
vous le redis mais il arrive à faire un
tout un cinéma enfin il a amené quand
même la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale à se prononcer sur le sujet je
sais pas si vous vous rendez compte
comme si ça concernait l'Assemblée
nationale je suis désolé de le dire vu
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui à
l'Assemblée nationale je pense que la
présidente devrait s'occuper de ce qui
se passe dans l'hémicycle parce qu'on
n'a jamais eu un tel foutoir donc se
prononcer sur une émission non mais je
trouve ça dingue
focus là-dessus parce que je trouve que
c'est un exemple pour nos enfants qui a
déplorable je voudrais dire un petit mot
personnel aussi ce que j'ai entendu un
moment qui disait que soi-disant on
était influencé pendant les émissions
moi j'ai fait trois ans de balance ton
poste pour ça je vous le dirai tout à
l'heure mais vous verrez voilà attaquer
pour ça ça c'est sûr et certain ça c'est
vraiment alors les immenses mais je
voulais vous dire que non seulement il y
a pas de consigne d'ailleurs si on en
avait donné vous me connaissez ça
n'aurait pas fonctionné puisque et
d'ailleurs c'est un peu nous cracher au
visage que d'imaginer que quand on est
chroniqueur on reçoit des consignes bien
sur un plateau les concerts la soupe je
sais pas pour qu'il se prend mais en
tout cas personnellement moi j'ai des
convictions pas lui donc j'ai trouvé que
cette attaque était complètement
déplacée je ne vais même pas sur le
sujet de la trahison je vais vous lire
nos échanges
merci en tout cas Mourad Ben écoutez
Cyril moi je vais être un peu plus
mesuré je pense pas qu'on puisse dire et
ça n'est pas audible que de dire que
Louis Boyard est mal habillé que c'est
un usurpateur je suis pas d'accord avec
ça parce que je crois qu'on perd en
crédibilité excusez-moi mais je crois
que pour qu'un propos soit audible il
faut être un tout petit peu plus dans la
mesure moi je voudrais revenir
simplement oui mais en fait Louis Boyard
n'est pas l'incarnation du diable sur
terre et je crois qu'il faut rester
mesuré sur la séquence sur la séquence
il y a un triple le problème il y a un
triple le problème que moi j'ai
identifié et il y a trois reproches
qu'on a fait principalement à Cyril le
premier reproche qu'on a fait à Cyril
c'est la loyauté sont une loyauté qui
qui l'aurait et qu'on lui a qu'on lui a
reproché d'abord sur la loyauté si on ne
parle pas de la loyauté on peut pas
comprendre cette séquence et on peut pas
comprendre le problème parce que ce qui
s'est passé ce qui a été gênant pour
tout le monde quand on a regardé cette
séquence
c'est qu'à mon sens le plateau était
déséquilibré puisque effectivement il
était il s'est retrouvé un petit peu
seul un petit peu isolé ça a donné un
sentiment effectivement des personnes
c'était pas un débat contre oui
[Musique]
qui a joué c'est lui qui a joué la carte
tout le monde
qui voulait ça loyauté c'est extrêmement
important parce que la loyauté c'est pas
l'apanage de TPMP c'est pas l'apanage de
Cyril Hanouna et ses chroniqueurs ça
existe partout ça veut dire que
effectivement les chroniqueurs sont
loyaux à Cyril Hanouna Cyril Hanouna et
loyal à son à son à son producteur mais
je veux dire moi j'ai l'habitude de
faire je finis simplement avant j'ai
l'habitude de faire énormément parce que
le producteur mais lui j'ai l'habitude
de faire énormément de de de télévision
sur mes dossiers etc je veux dire ça
existe partout il y a aucun groupe en
France où vous pouvez critiquer les
actionnaires majoritaires etc je passe
dans toutes les chaînes j'ai jamais
entendu sur TF1 Martin Bouygues etc je
dirais mais elle existe partout tout le
temps elle existe dans tous les partis
politiques on suit la politique et vous
la suivez peut-être plus que moi aucun
parti politique où on peut critiquer qui
de Macron de Jean-Luc Mélenchon de
Marine Le Pen personne ne va jamais
critiquer et cette loyauté elle existe
partout et tout le temps ça c'est sur le
premier point et d'ailleurs on l'a vu
pour pour Alexis Corbière et pour
Madame Garrido on voit bien que
justement ils sont face à un conflit de
loyauté ce qu'on appelle un conflit de
loyauté puisque il y a la loyauté qu'ils
ont envers vous et la loi était qu'ils
ont envers le Parti et ça pose une
problématique ça pose un problème donc
ils ont ils ont fait ils ont montré leur
loyauté que ce soit Jean-Luc Mélenchon
pas je trouve voilà personnellement
il est même pas rentrer dans le débat
qu'on voulait faire il est venu pour
exister il est venu pour faire son buzz
je pense que tout le week-end il a du
surkiffer parce qu'il a vu son nom
partout avec un ego surdimensionné et
jusqu'au Fort Boyard
aujourd'hui parce que sa petite
conférence de presse à 14h30 elle était
grotes parce que pardon c'est quand même
personne j'aurais tellement préféré
qu'ils disent voilà pas de conférence de
presse pas de machin pas de j'attaque tu
sais quoi on redescend tous je reviens
en émission on se parle ça aurait été
tellement plus grand et plus courageux
que cette conférence de presse ridicule
à 14h à la Formule 1 Invitation il a pas
répondu
20h20 on est déjà 13h je vous dis parce
que il y a les quatre députés qu'on
voudrait euh voilà entendre également
euh Laurence que tu as quelque chose à
ajouter Mourad alors moi juste sur sur
la montée de l'extrême droite ça pour le
coup je voudrais quand même je voudrais
quand même en dire un mot parce que
c'est là où à mon sens on on sort du
cadre de de ce qui s'est passé pour
entrer dans quelque chose de plus
positif moi je voudrais simplement dire
la vérité qu'elle amène dans votre
émission la première fois que vous
m'avez invité c'était pour faire face à
Jean Messia et pour pour pouvoir lui
répondre de façon absolument libre ce
que j'ai ce que ce que j'ai fait lors de
mon premier passage et vous m'avez
réinvité à de nombreuses reprises dont
la parfois face à Gérald Darmanin pour
effectivement avoir une liberté
d'expression totale et où j'ai pu dire
mon désaccord à de nombreuses reprises
donc ça pour le coup je crois que c'est
un faux procès et je crois qu'au
contraire c'est la liberté d'expression
qui prime dans votre émission une
liberté d'expression qui se veut être
dans la lignée effectivement on en a
parlé tout à l'heure des émissions comme
apostrophe comme droit de réponse qui
existait dans les années 80 où il y a
une vraie liberté d'expression on peut
s'invctiver parfois s'insulter on a plus
le droit de le faire aujourd'hui mais en
tout état de cause c'est dans cette
lignée que je viens en tout cas moi à
chaque fois que je suis venu c'est avec
effectivement une ligue liberté
d'expression totale et entière merci
que j'insistais
j'abusais mais pas du tout monsieur je
suis sûr qu'on est loin encore de la
vérité de la dangerosité de ce type de
personnage et vous verrez ce qui va se
passer après et vous verrez qu'à
l'impact ça peut avoir sur l'institution
qu'elle a semblée nationale est-ce que
racisme c'est de pas serrer la main par
exemple d'un député du rassemblement
ou est-ce que le vrai racisme c'est pas
de participer à une manifestation qui se
termine par mort aux juif avec des gens
de la fille